nous allons écouter les enfants parler
de leur vie de leurs rêves de leurs
peurs toi tu as tu as 13 ans ça fait 3
ans que tu es en France tu es tu vis
dans l'orphelina de d'ouvre la délivrand
c'est ça près de camp avec 30 enfants
libanais toi tu as perdu ta mère ton
frère lors d'un bombardement à Beyrouth
et toi-même tu as été à ce moment-là tu
as reçu des éclats but et tu as été
blessé on te demande souvent ce que
c'est les traces que tu as sur le visage
oui oui ça t'ennuie quand on t'en parle
ou tu préfères qu'on t'en parle pas
trop est-ce que tu as envie d'en parler
là
oui ou alors tu tu peux raconter un peu
comment ça se passé j'étais beou quand
je suis né il y a fait la guerre moi mon
frère il est mort on était assis à côté
de la fenêtre une
bombe descendu à côté de nous elle dit
elle nous a dit ma mère allez à côté de
moi je dit non on va jouer une deuxième
bombe est descendue je suis allée à côté
de chauvage j'ai senti que quelque chose
descentait sur moi j'aiu une bombe tombé
sur moi et tout à coup après coup de
Pierr sur moi et des tout ça j'ai pousé
toute ma force je suis allé à côté de
mon père mon père est parti pour
chercher l'ambulance il a couru à peu
près 2 km sous de bombardement
elle plé je lui dit moi je ve aller avec
toi il m'a dit non reste ici il resté et
nous ont transporté en première méthode
pour aller à l'hôpital parce que il y
avait beaucoup de bombardement c'est
pour ça c'est comme ça ma mère 3 jours
après ils ont trouvé mon frère en sous
de ruine de la
maison parce que vous l'avez pas trouvé
tout de suite non on a cherché partout
on n pas TR et toi à ce moment-là
qu'est-ce qui t''est arrivé donc tu tu
étais à l'hôpital ouaisétais à l'hôpital
à l'hôpital parce que
tutaissou après quand je sortis de
l'hôpital il
m'ont transporté à montagne chez ma
grande t
et là-bas mon père il m'a dit ta mère
est morte et ton frère aussi là j'ai
pleuré un petit
peu après qu'est-ce que tu t'es dit il
faut que je sois costaud c'est ça fa que
je sois
courage plus que je pense faut que je
pense
à
études avant qu' avant qu'il
t'arrive tout ça est-ce que tu avais
pensé ça pouvait est-ce que tu avais
déjà pensé comme ça que l'un d'entre
vous pouvait mourir non pourtant tu
vivais au milieu de la guerre est-ce que
tu te rappelles quand tu arrivé en
France oui je suis arrivé en France
j'avais un peu de TIC tu avais des tics
ouais parce que tu étais oisséouis Cuse
de bombardement tu as fallu beaucoup de
temps pour que tu te sentes bien
ouais et alors tu tu as rencontré là le
père abina ouai
est responsable mais et tout ça et tu le
considères un peu comme ton père ouais
elleimis comme ma mère
aimis comme ta mère et je pense toujours
à ma mère mais il y a aussi d'autres
mère tu penses comment à ta maman dans
mon cœur je regarde comme ça par quelque
fois je pense à
elle je dis elles sont bien dans le
ciel je dis elles se sent bien dans le
ciel là où tu vis avec donc les 30
enfants libanais qui on entre qui ont
quel
âge 5 ans à 16 ans 5 à 16 ans vous
parlez du Liban entre vous oui
oui qu'est-ce que vous
dites on dit quand plus tard quand on va
aller au Liban on va reconstruire le
Liban on va faire la
paix va voir la paix dans tous les pays
faut pas avoir la
guerre est-ce que toi par exemple tu
veux retourner au Liban plus tard ou tu
veux rester en
France ça dépend sil y a encore la
guerre au Liban je resterai en
France si il n'y a plus je retourne au
Liban c'est mon pays je
temps et toi tu tu travailles pour avoir
maintenant un métier pour pouvoir aller
là-bas aider après oui qu'estce
qu'est-ce que tu voudrais faire plus
tard toi un prêtre on me le Perre
qué tu vas être prêtre ouais le père
dont tu parles c'est lui qui qui
s'occupe c'est ça de de
l'orphelina toi tu tu veux être prête
pour pour aider les autres oui est-ce
que toi tu as eu aussi cette envie de
vengeance
non je pardonne à T ceux qui ont dit ma
mère et tu pardonnes
ouais comment tu fais pour pardonner je
pardonne parce que si j' pardonne pas
on reste toujours dans la
haine si on pardonne on reste toujours
heureux dans notre
vie toi tu as décidé d'être heureux
ou qu'est-ce que tu aimes bien faire
chanter je voudrais chanter ah tu
voudrais chanter tu as une belle voix ou
et tu voudrais chanter plus tard ou
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
[Musique]
magnifique une superbe voix
alors Ellie toi tu as tu as souffert tu
es déjà devenu même adulte non c'est ce
que tu te dis tant en tant adulte avant
l'heure tu as grandi trop vite tu te l'
dis ça
op vite la
Guer pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
in mire Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche